but the thing is we're not gonna talk
about harvey gotten weinstein because
it's too soon but i do want to talk
about
this book i just found that was laying
on that shelf
it's the book of the forty eight four
eight four eight forty eight i wanna say
it
i know but you couldn't find the title i
don't know
all right it's a book i found called the
440 40
48 48 laws of power 40 by robert greene
i don't know if you guys know this but
i like to randomly open up and read a
power interesting is that cool yeah
let's do it so
in this there's 48 powers and number
three conceal your intentions
example um hey
i have a booty movie studio you know and
uh i have a bunch of movies i'm
producing
you're an actress come to my
one i'll show you always say less than
necessary
what kind of movie is it i don't know
check out my hotel room hotel room
interesting yeah it's interesting isn't
it yeah and let's go to
the next one chapter five it no chapter
six
so much depends on reputation guard it
with your life
i don't think he did well [ __ ] up sir
yeah i think other people guarded it for
him
and that's the disease of hollywood i
think that they
you know it was an open secret for
decades upon decades and we kind of just
like
happily swept it he does i mean okay
what he did
is absolutely evil
all right to sexually harass and rape
other people
bat boy or girl and to use your power in
that way
is absolutely evil okay
okay but
period no there's actually no but it's
period oh yeah period now new sentence
yeah you thought you thought
yeah and the new thought is pulp fiction
was a great movie that
you said that i didn't say that that's
what you were going to say i was going
to say that i read your mind
how dare you i was going to say that it
is a good movie you're going to treat
him out after you put his dick on your
forehead how dare you
instantly okay you know when i first met
bobby um you used to tell me often that
um bill cosby was a creep this was three
two years before
he got you know outed for you know
basically drugging women
but i remember you telling my mom my
mom's like i love bill cosby
and you always used to tell me like oh
he's the biggest creep and it's an open
it's a it's
it's a well-known thing you would just
hear stories from people like i
worked with a on a movie and the makeup
artist
was interning for the cosby show or
whatever yeah and this is years ago and
she said um
yeah i was interning wasn't really
making any money
and i got to do cosby like was that
great change your life
well he took his hand
and he clawed my left breast as hard as
he could
like the nails digging into her breast
and he said there's nothing you can do
about this
wow yeah i'm so there are people out
there
that behave in this way so yeah this is
essentially just the tip of the iceberg
he didn't
claw no titty but he probably did worse
things probably clawed the [ __ ] out of
her titty he probably did worse
he looks like a claw of a titty that tie
magazine photo but the thing is is that
i think that i think that
um this kind of behavior has been going
on for
since mankind can you open the door i
mean i mean
you know we were talking about genghis
khan kangaskhan yeah you what did you
what was that stat you just said
uh if the uh one-fifth of the world
population is uh related
uh or descended from so basically baby
you and i are related
probably us yeah we're probably the
closest yeah
georgia genghis khan is down our line
yeah isn't that crazy how many
concubines did he have
like over 200 yeah and right now one in
200 men are related or have the dna
in the body oh that's incredible yeah i
mean he did some